e
e e
test I can hear you test no it's the
same thing okay maybe it's for the
speaker
welcome to the subcommittee meeting on
House Bill um 637 I believe correct I
don't have the notice in front of me uh
thank you um the subcommittee will only
be looking at this bill as this is the
only one that has been noticed um
essentially this bill has was presented
to us as a way to make whole the
employees who were not who who were
unintentionally not included in um
Senate Bill 57 which was then
incorporated into the budget in uh
2023 we had our researcher Brad gedin
look and he has a nice comparison for us
on what the actual changes were in those
statutes made by House Bill 2 um and I
did further research looking at the full
Senate report and Senate hearing report
that followed the all of Senate Bill 57
through its process um I did reduce that
document from the 74 Pages down to about
34 or so just so that I wasn't print
killing extra trees while trying to get
the information that I thought might be
relevant to us I can send that all out
to the committee and it's all available
if you look up Senate bill 57 from
2023 you go into the bill history and
then um there's a part where you can
click on the Senate
documents the reason I'm looking into
this information and why I think it's
relevant is that we were told that this
bill was brought to us because it was an
oversight that was not caught um to not
include the employees who had already
retired pre prior to enactment of the
language in
2023 as it stands I have the bill as
introduced that has a fiscal note for
the entire kitten Kaboodle um including
everybody who had the had the change in
their benefits because of the the budget
in
2023 um and that was pretty
significant that was $1.4 Million to the
state this year and $ 5.74 million to
the
municipalities and because those are
calculated every two years that we're
all going to be paying that difference
in our proper property tax this year
because that increase of the $5.7
million was not included until um this
new B bium with our tax rates so that's
being paid by um by the employers which
are the residents of our towns and
school districts um additionally looking
at the fiscal note that is in here from
the prev from the bill that started this
whole thing um that the New Hampshire
retirement system actuary projected an
increase in Actuarial accured liability
by $45 million based on the provision of
the bill which would be amortised over a
fixed period of no longer than 20 years
so this is a significant financial
outlay and that is I believe a large
part of why the Senate put that into the
budget in 2023 as opposed to having a
very expensive Bill run along separately
without being part of the budget process
because quite frankly you don't want to
spend that amount of money without doing
that appropriately in the budget so I
look to the history of this bill so we
in our little packets that we have from
the Senate hearing as you flip through
you get to a part that has the committee
me minutes and it has the calendar
notice from the January 18th hearing
they actually give a really great
rundown from the senate about what
happens um and notes and minutes from it
that is really helpful when you're
looking at the bills for those of you
who are newer to the legislature so
there was the the the Pres people who
presented um Senator the senator
introduced it and then Brian Hawkins
from the Nea supported the bill and then
um the testim neutral information
presented by Marty carlan of the New
Hampshire retirement system actually
highlighted at that point that the bill
would be considered prospective which
means that anyone who retired before the
effective date would not be affected and
this bill only affects those that
retired on or after that
date so that's sort of where I get to a
disconnect on what we were told when the
bill was introduced um that this had
been an oversight because the this
language the current language pass
Senate executive departments and
administration committee um on consent
with the initially introduced language
which was prospective and had no
retroactive sections then it passed
Senate finance and then was tabled on
the floor so it could be included in the
budget it was known at that point as
well that this was prospective language
um expensive prospective language but
prospective language and then it was
added into the budget also knowing that
it was prospective legislation that was
going to unfortunately leave a portion
of our retirees be
behind this was a policy decision by the
senate in a year when we had far more
money than we have this year and this is
something that perhaps they may be
looking to bring again in the budget but
this is this th
this that was a policy decision um it
was not an oversight and looking at that
looking at this information um I think
that that's really important to know I
don't know if there's anybody who wants
to say anything at this point
um
no um so I do want to say that I wish I
wish we all had all the money in the
budget to be able to give everybody
everything that they deserve because the
people who work for our State the people
who work for our schools do an
incredibly important job um right now we
are looking at addressing the issues for
the group two employees who were hired
on with one set of terms for their
pensions and then that was changed in 20
um 2011 2012 time period so there's a
very expensive very important bill that
is moving forward and likely will be in
the state budget um this is also very
very important however when these
employees took their re enironment they
knew the terms that they had and it was
stated in public testimony that it was
not part of the bill at that time um as
much as I would like to be able to give
this I am also looking at all of our
taxpayers throughout um and with that I
think that it would make sense for us to
unfortunately recommend this is an
expedient to legislate because because
because we have to look at every penny
that we have and this was not an
oversight on the part of the Senate it
was a policy decision so um I'm going to
move I
do I have a second second so any
discussion yes representative Howard
thank you so I I'm uh in opposition to
the itl motion because I believe that
when we are creating contracts with
individuals uh No Matter What entity we
need to make sure that we're following
through on these contracts and the thing
is is that as is uh we have a retirement
age that uh is different than what
Social Security can provide and the
thing is is that we should clearly make
those the same it is forcing people uh
to work an extra two years unnecessarily
uh when they could request the
retirement uh at 65 instead of 67 so
with that I I can't say that I can
support the itl motion and I will be uh
looking for an OTP thank you thank you
there are other comments uh
representative SLA Loi how do I say it
again sloty thank you I get nervous when
I say people's names SL
okay uh I I you mentioned uh the
previous speaker mentioned um uh
obligations contractual obligations I
I'm curious is there any specific
contractual obligation that you're aware
of that that you spoke to or is it uh
some
other uh you know is there something
else that I'm unaware of
potentially when we're talking about
retirement contracts it's looking I mean
there are different plans for people and
it depends on what those individuals
choose but members of the New Hampshire
retirement system uh are basically
promised things from the state of New
Hampshire uh I uh you know I'm
I'm I still think that it's something
where we do need to provide uh These
funds to people and make sure that we
can provide retirement at these uh lower
ages
but you know again
opinions thank you thank you and um yes
questions um so uh this this is a
subcommittee work session it's not a
hearing um so I wanted have our
discussion here as well I appreciate
that you all came out in the snow um and
I I guess I will say one other thing
although we're in the voting mode I
probably should have t asked for any
anything at that point
so normally it's not a matter of taking
testimony or hearing from people in a
subcommittee work session but given that
you guys drove out in the snow um do you
mind if I just give each of you maybe
two or three minutes each just because
you did make the drive in the snow um I
will I know it's not exactly correct
procedure I guess I'll I'll withdraw my
motion and then we'll make it again so
we've withdrawn the motion and withdrawn
the second so that since you've you've
uh made the trip in the snow we can hear
from each of you if you'd like to we'll
need to have a pink card from you but
I'll give you two or three
minutes thanks up up to the microphone
and turn it on because this is live
streamed so the record can you wait till
you put the microphone on oh yeah yes
for the record Bob blell uh representing
the state employees
Association um I I guess I'm a bit
confused because this is my 28th session
and I've been to a lot of
subcommittees um which involves the
public so I'm a little bit confused
because yes it's a work session however
it's a work session for not only
legislators but also from the public and
I understand the whole testimony
situation but it's been my
experience that um there's a
conversation during these I've had many
conversations and work sessions in this
room for Edna for decades so am I to
understand that um before you take the
vote you're not going to include us just
a procedural thing is something changed
um actually the procedures are always
that uh the hearings are open for
everybody who wants to testify
subcommittees that is to the discretion
of the chair I have been on many
subcommittees where it does not reopen
public testimony um I was trying to be
sensitive to the weather but I also need
to be sensitive to the fact that you all
came out as well that's why I withdrew
my motion and we withdrew the second so
that we could have this discussion so we
didn't I didn't hear any discussion on
policy I heard a lot of discussion about
um finances um which would be for a
different committee so I'm I'm trying to
understand where we're at can we have a
conversation about about the actual
policy and the impact this has on
retirees uh so thank you for bringing
that up as as to the policy um back in
1988 the retirement were linked to the
Social Security Federal benefits and it
was calculated with an equation that had
that um some times there were actually
very significant reductions because of
those Social Security aspects instead of
having a straight level amount that you
would have over your entire retired
career there was the higher calculation
prior to the retirement age so that
there was a bonus before you were able
to reach your full Med uh full Social
Security retirement age I think a lot of
this is looking at whether it's a
reduction when you take your social
security or if the state has offered a
bonus to those who do choose to retire
early knowing that they're not able to
have that Social Security okay um I do
see that as the bonus when you're
retiring early because in almost any
other place you don't get a bonus for
retiring early Social Security if it
take you take it early it's reduced um a
lot of other pensions if you retire
early it's reduced because of the longer
time period And for those of us who have
to contribute for our retirements it's
also reduced because you have it over a
lower longer Horizon so I I I do
remember um 1988 um it was Senate Bill
327 and when that went into effect okay
it was a Del
linkage between the federal and the
state because they changed the
age from 65 to 67 we did not change
anything at that time so that that that
created a d linkage which right off the
bat that retiree got a 10% reduction
which they did not see before
so I'm I just want to make sure
everybody understands the full history
and um it's it's one of those like in
that if you look at that representative
you'll see the history they do an
example of um someone who um retires at
the age of 60 and it's a $50,000 example
pension this example is is provided in
that in that bill history by the New
Hampshire retirement system so it's not
like like from any particular angle it's
it is what it is and I would I would
encourage everybody to to review the
bill history on that to understand the
policy of what this bill this bill is
about fairness this bill is about
fairness for these people whether or not
it was understood by some or not last
year or two years ago now
um you're right at the time it was a it
was a financial decision made by the
finance
committees and the policy people are the
ones who pushed it forward in the Senate
without regarding um having the the the
finance and and the budget writers have
those discussions so whether or not they
knew it was going to leave some people
out or not the fact is people are left
out and what this bill is trying to do
is to make everybody in the system
whole well thank you for that um looking
at the calculat prior to the entire was
the entire number system redone in when
it was delink because it is calculated
as uh 166 of the final compensation
after 65 and um and prior to that it's
160 yes was it 160 through throughout or
was it uh 160 throughout prior to that
or was it 166 prior to that or was it a
different
number I want to make sure I give you
the the most accurate best number I
don't have that off the top of my head
right now but I do want to get that
correct answer for all of you that's a
very good question okay thank you
because uh that was a policy decision
made in the Senate policy committee
before it was sent to the Senate finance
committee and they were aware of it and
they made that policy decision but I
appreciate that you're advocating for
everybody that you represent sure we we
just have to look at the fairness to
everybody so thank you well you're
looking at the policy and and I just I
get a little I always get a little
concerned when policy committees are are
taking bills because of financial
thoughts
thank you for your for your testimony
all right I appreciate you guys thanks
drive
safe
yes yes hello my name is Karen Irwin and
for the record I am the one that
initiated this this year this bill um I
am one of those that got captured in
this I will say it was a definition
issue if you look at the language they
considered the language seemed to
support everyone it said retiree members
it was how the fiscal note was developed
that did find retirees members as an
active member of employment not a retire
member of employment you would think
when the language is reflected about
retirees it would have encapsulated
everyone I do remember when Senator
Bradley pushed this through and he was a
champion behind this Senate Bill 57 I
asked him I said do you realize that
those that have already retired were not
included in this 45 million because the
fiscal note didn't match the language of
the bill that is the history that I'm
familiar with if you look at that
language there's no
differentiation of what a retiring
member is in any kind of legislative
support so it was a determination by I'm
sorry sorry but the retirement system to
Define retiree member as somebody that
was only an active employee that had not
yet retired so we there's most of us now
that are retiring at this time frame and
I put that in my testimony would be age
you know in the year birth date 1958 to
probably
1962 that's my estimation of what those
ages that are captured in this and
anybody 1960 and older are now full
retirement is
67 so the what Bob was referring to is
it had been a disconnect it wasn't a
bonus it was a reduction because uh
retirees got Social Security and so when
they got Social Security added they said
we can reduce your pension by 10%
because you're getting more money that
disconnect existed for over 20 years
till Senate Bill 57 I don't 20 or more
years you know maybe I guess it's 19
that'll be you know 35 years it was a
disconnect that people were like okay I
have to pay more for my
medical I can't take my Social Security
without getting a a discount and I
reflected to you in my age group I would
be taking it two years early if I really
needed that money I would need I and
because I couldn't support that 10%
decrease that loss in
income then I would also have to take my
Social Security two years early so those
two decreases were in my case with 36
years in the retirement system
$836 I think is what I said but I just
wanted to get that history for you it
really wasn't all knowledgeable because
the one that was leading the charge
didn't even know it until I pointed it
out to him and it was too late in the
game you know they all said to me it was
too late in the game to go back and get
another fiscal note or do anything so
they had to go through and support
everybody supported it just being active
members and not retiree members and so
we're simply asking it for for it to be
you know fair and and um and what I also
testified to is because we're recent
retirees um in my case I had
$34,000 in my person
account my cut was $4.69 I think you
know and that was just mine but um and
if you kind of if you kick it out
because I haven't used up all my money
for six years you let us have the
continued amount till we've reach four
um you know age 67 in my case that it
really doesn't kick in that um unfunded
liability to much later because all of
our pensions come out of that first
roughly six years of our money first so
to speak our money and um the 7% we put
in all over all those years and
Everything's Relative because depends on
how many years you have but it's all
kind of a relative thing so my 10% is
that amount because I have a lot of
years in you know other people won't
have much so I hope you will go to the
policy of this bill because if you look
at the history it is unfair that and it
was an oversight as far as I was
concerned because they was how it was
defined which is not in Statue again on
the fiscal note so uh thank you for this
time though and I hope you will change
your mind on that idea with this history
and let it go I do think there's things
that could be done on the fiscal side to
support um maybe an alternative because
this is a little narrow window of time
basically I showed in my spreadsheet it
was from this fiscal year going to about
30 is what you would capture everybody
you know and so I'm not understanding
such a big number still I mean I know
the legislature has total control over
what they're doing here and um I'm just
let it get to the next step you know and
let let us hash through the fiscal stuff
with somebody because that 45 million
ion is in the retirement system even if
you looked at it as and the assumed rate
of return was 6.75 and I think we earned
9.8 last year you know even if you
looked at that money and said maybe that
2% could help pay for this you know I
was something it seems like we could do
something on that those lines you could
tie it together and make it full circle
because the language is there in the
first place it really isn't defined and
so if the Lang which was to me an
oversight I'm it wasn't clearly spelled
out to even the legislators that we were
leaving out a section of people so thank
you did the did the any of the terms of
your retirement change though in that
period um from the time when you chose
to retire early were they the same terms
that you retired under that you're still
um living under
today did the terms ever change no it
was it was always making up for the
original intention way back when was
that you would not get impacted and
everybody's like whoever hears of a
pension going down after you retire
usually you get a flat pension and so it
was a purpose legislative intent to
decrease it at Social Security age never
was an intent to do anything else it was
just that it cost so much money you know
if you're going to change it
forever that they didn't have the money
from year to year to do it now they've
done the Lion's Share of this but you
know it seems like there's there's a way
to alternatively looking at this for
finance but that that to me is a finance
decision and I wish you would pass this
on the principle that it is kind of
unfair and I really if you go look at
the language and do your analysis you
will see what I'm saying in the language
you would not support that it would
leave out a group of people that were
actual retirees so know that's the
history no thank you for that history
and um in the history from the Senate it
was brought up on January 18th of 2023
um Unfortunately they did have time
where they could have amended that but
they they chose not to and I'm really
sorry for that but thank you well I mean
this was on the last days you know I
would talked to Jeb Bradley and CU and
he wasn't aware of that
so thank you are there any questions
from the he was Senate President during
that time
yes I'm
sorry sorry representative Howard thank
you for taking my question so I was
curious if you had any information about
some of the other states in the country
and whether or not uh they are facing
similar problems with their Retirement
Systems
um I guess I would you know wouldn't
Define it
as a problem it was just our policy to
decrease so I don't think any other you
know I don't know of any other states
where they decrease the amount of um
money based on reaching Social Security
age I don't know of anybody that has
that tie in but so I don't have that
information
but yeah thank you thank you and if you
can make sure to send a pain card up
that'd be help yeah thank you
I what did I do bar
I I I okay thank
you yes you wanted to speak yes please
thank you so um it seems to me there are
couple of things happening here and
maybe it's just because I'm new and I'm
not understanding which is uh that that
happens a lot but um
the when I heard discussion um at the
beginning it did sound like it was the
finances that would be the reason that
we would be voting against that and that
is not what my understanding was of role
of this committee I understood us to be
um looking at the fairness and the
equity of the policy um and I understood
this bill to be cleaning up a mistake
now you're you're sharing um and I
appreciate it um that You' say that it
could have 50 Senate Bill 57 could have
been fixed on the Senate side um which
is contrary to what I'm hearing from
people who are testifying today and I
would like um to have more time to dig
into that because I don't feel as though
we have enough information I appreciate
what what you said Madam chair um and
and because you said it I want to go and
study it I am not particularly
comfortable um where there is a conflict
uh between two people's understanding
moving forward and I'm especially not
comfortable doing that um at a time
where where um it sounded to me like we
were getting at a inexpedient to
legislate
recommendation because of how much this
was going to cost us instead of the
question of whether or not um we should
be we should be doing this for for
people who were participating in the
system so that might those are my two
cents maybe I'm misunderstanding um but
i' i' i' particularly appreciate not
taking a vote on this today thank you
thank you um I do agree that
understanding the true legislative
history of this bill is important and
that's why the records from the Senate
hearing on January 18th it is in the
minutes that it was raised it was voted
without changing it um I I can get the
particular dates it was voted in
committee and on the floor from Edna in
the Senate without changing it it was
heard in finance again in the Senate
where it was brought up and it was not
changed and then it was added to the
budget which was a whole another one
which I think is an 800 page committee
report so I definitely didn't print that
one um but I can find the specific pages
from that where it was brought up again
and um there were various Advocates who
continued to Advocate just for those
people who had not yet retired and there
was not advocacy um from the groups for
those who had previously retired and um
although I'm sure that individuals were
advocating for that but I but um most of
it was in support of moving forward with
those who they could so it was a policy
decision and since this was brought to
us to clean up an inadvertent oversight
that was not an inadvertent oversight it
is a policy issue um further we are the
only it seems that we're the only state
that does pay people more before they
reach full retirement age um and if
we're whether one of a few states that
pay more before full retirement age or
the only one that pays more before full
retirement age that is to make sure that
people are not facing as many challenges
when they're not able to also receive
Social Security so with that I will
again move in expedient to legislate
okay and um more discussion or should we
just go ahead and
vote so we will go ahead and vote uh
representative
sers yes representative SL
yes uh representative Howard no and
representative J no and representative
Lon votes yes so it's a 3-2
recommendation out of the subcommittee
um with that I will close the
subcommittee hearing um we will schedule
another subcommittee hearing likely
after session next week for other bills
that we have assuming that we don't have
a larger floor schedule than we had
today so thank you for that um and have
a